the covid vaccines made by moderna and
pfizer were developed and brought to
market at a blistering pace
the fastest vaccine development in
western history but their distribution
has been hobbled by poor planning
and rigid eligibility rules vaccine
distribution is going very very badly
nationwide the initial vaccine rollout
has been rocky
doses are being thawed and they're not
being administered
because the vaccine ships in batches and
expires quickly once thawed
precious doses have been pitched when
eligible recipients weren't readily
available
or missed their appointments new york
governor andrew cuomo threatened fines
of a million dollars for health care
providers who vaccinate people out of
turn
the most recent cdc data shows that of
the more than 30 million doses shipped
only about 11 million have been used and
those are mostly first doses
the pfizer and moderna vaccines are both
given as two identical shots
three and four weeks apart respectively
although the trump administration has
since reversed course
it initially stockpiled one dose for
everyone shipped
doctors and epidemiologists worry that
we're losing the race against surging
infections and new strains
that spread more easily and may be more
likely to cause reinfection
the problem with the vaccine rollout is
that it was centrally planned
in a way that didn't give local
officials and healthcare workers enough
flexibility
to adjust to the realities on the ground
and to make trade-offs
between treating as many people as
possible and strictly adhering to the
rules
the idea of keeping the second doses in
reserve
was really nuts we ought to trust the
supply chain
give out as many first doses as you can
even if you're still going to try and
give out the
you know second dose at 21 or 28 days
just trust the supply chain to do that
alex taverock is an economist at george
mason university
who consulted with the trump
administration the world bank and
foreign governments on optimal ways to
incentivize rapid development of a
coveted vaccine
he says that the decision to hold half
the vaccine supply in reserve
is an example of a failure to think in
terms of trade-offs
the first dose's first approach which
the uk recently adopted
would allocate all available vaccines to
be used as first doses
while pushing off second doses for weeks
or even months until production can
catch up
that means you can give twice as many
first doses if you instead of giving a
second dose
you give a first dose of somebody else
you can have two people
who are protected at an eighty percent
efficacy rate
as opposed to one person who's protected
at a 95 percent
efficacy rate but there are additional
advantages when you
push out the first doses faster you get
to hurt immunity faster
you push down r so the more you spread
out the first doses
the slower the transmission rate of the
virus is
because now fewer people are getting the
disease
and it looks like then fewer people will
be transmitting the disease
the current approach of giving boosters
at three and four weeks is based on what
pfizer and moderna evaluated in their
clinical trials
but waiting longer likely won't
significantly reduce the vaccine's
effectiveness
at 21 or 28 days that is not a magical
number that is not a number which is
set in stone by you know the vaccine
gods a lot of vaccines
you get the booster months later even
years later it's still good
one of the reasons that companies chose
that very short time
they wanted quite rightly to get the
clinical trials done
so for the astrazeneca vaccine we
actually know the longer booster
is more effective and that could be true
for some of these other vaccines as well
from the uk
this more contagious version of the
virus the new variant of coronavirus is
out of control critics of this approach
argue that partial immunity
from a single dose might create
dangerous strains under a process known
as selection
pressure where random mutations create
new strains
that can invade the antibodies generated
by the current vaccines
i am a little bit puzzled when some of
the vaccine people make this argument
because
the fda was willing to accept
a vaccine with a efficacy rate of 50
percent
much lower than we're getting now nobody
at that time was saying
oh no no no we can't do that if we have
a vaccine with 50
efficacy will get viral mutation it'll
be worse than having no vaccine at all
nobody made that argument back then
proponents of first doses first say that
dangerous strains have already emerged
in the absence of selection pressure
and that the priority right now should
be ending the pandemic as quickly as
possible
even if that means trying an untested
low-risk gamble
if you switch to first doses first you
have the option of switching back
you learn whether it works or not if it
does work you've made the right decision
if it doesn't work you can go back to
second doses if you stick with second
doses
you never learn whether you might have
been wrong we will learn something from
the british trials
we'll learn something from what's
happening in quebec we will learn
something
in the united states if we go to first
doses first united states is in a
relatively good position because of
operation warp speed
the rest of the world is going to have a
much bigger shortage
than the united states so the world
really needs to
maximize the value of these vaccines the
vaccines are extremely valuable
the uk is also running trials on
fractional dosing
which would extend supply by giving
doses as small as one half the
prescribed amount
in the past with yellow fever and with
polio
in an emergency situation where supplies
were really scarce
the who went to fractional dosing
and that can also uh work extremely well
so what we
learned from the moderna trials is that
at least for
adults between you know 20 and 55 a half
dose
appears to work just as well as a full
dose we just heard from the uk that
they're just trying to hit as many
people at once
why not do something like that and space
out the time between doses
but there are no plans to follow the
uk's approach of vaccinating more widely
by pushing off the second dose for the
modern vaccine
two doses half the dose immunizing
double the number of people with the
doses we have
we know it induces identical immune
response
monsev slowly who headed up operation
warp speed expressed interest in
stretching the moderna vaccine
through fractional dosing of course
ultimately it will be an fda decision
and what's been extremely frustrating is
that the fda
has a medical mindset and not a public
health mindset
what economists are good at is making
decisions under uncertainty and scarcity
and it's being hard-nosed and thinking
about probabilities
thinking about risk expected value
economists are very
good at saying let's do the thing which
saves the most lives in israel they're
just pulling people off the street and
giving them a vaccination right there on
the spot
in new york that will get you arrested
and that'll get you fined
it might be better particularly at this
stage just to say go go go
and vaccinate as many people as you can
and certainly it's a terrible idea
to penalize people when they take
actions which are in favor of the public
health